[Music]
hey dad is Mohammad Ahsan and welcome to
my dart programming language tutorial
that is the main programming language to
develop cross-platform mobile
application using flatter framework in
this video tutorial I will discuss the
fundamental features of dart programming
language if you know any other
programming language then you will find
out is really easy to understand so no
more talking let's begin to install dart
is decay in your system please visit 8
HT TPS and dart dot div and here you
will see that there is a get dirt link
just click that on that menu and here
you will see there is three version
windows linux and mac so if you are
using Windows just follow the
instruction to install that is decay in
your system as I use Mac so I followed
this Mac instruction and I already
installed dart in my system currently
there is version 2.3 which I am also
using for this lesson as well to write
dart code you can choose any editor but
I personally prefer Visual Studio code
editors so if you want to use Visual
Studio coded or you can install from
this web page and there is also Mac
Windows and Linux version as I'm using
Mac so I install the Mac version also if
you do not want to install the dart SDK
or the Visual Studio code editor in your
system you just want to check out dirt
by just typing the code in a wave editor
you can just use the dart pet so the
address is dark pet dot dot length over
G here you will see this interface and
for example here is the main function
and suppose here I write print hello
world one and I just click run and you
two will show compile the program and
show the output in the right side window
so if you want you can also use this
dart pet but I personally prefer to use
Visual Studio code editor and run dart
code in the system so currently I open
my Visual Studio code
and here you will see the visual code
editor and to highlight the scene tip
you should install a dart extension to
instruct that extension in the visual
code is studio code editor you have to
click view then here you will see
extension just click on it and here you
if you search dart you will see that
three point one point zero there is an
extension which I already installed so
if you are using Visual Studio code
editor you just find out this dart
extension and click in stand and it will
be installed in your visual is - code
editor and then if you click view
Explorer then you will see this
interface as well
so currently I created this playground
dot d R AR T so dot code extension is da
R T so I created this playground or dart
file in my desktop demo directory where
I will write some code and execute in
the terminal so if you do not see any
terminal window in Visual Studio code
editor just click terminal and then
click new terminal so here you will get
the current directory location
automatically so if I want to run this
playground dot dot so what I have to
type d AR teetered and then the file
name so playground dot dot in my case
and if I click run I I can see the
output of the program here so I do not
need to open this terminal window
separately I just you I just can use
this built-in terminal feature in Visual
Studio code editor
[Music]
dart is a static type programming
language it is also a compiled
programming language so it static type
means if you defined a variable as
string you cannot assign other values
like integer or double on that is
king-type variable though there is an
exception like there is a type called
dynamic which you can use to store any
kind of values I will discuss that on
later another thing is that that
supports two type of compilation one is
called a or T or ahead of time another
is called JIT or just-in-time
compilation so when we want to run a
dart program we have to compile it and
then run but it happens automatically so
when we write a dart program and we just
run it automatically complex on the fly
and this is called just-in-time
compilation and when we deploy our final
product then it will be compiled as a Oh
T or a dove term time compilation with
some optimization let's write a dart
program so every dot program starts with
a with the main function so let's write
a main function void main so your main
is a function and what means this
function returns nothing if you want you
can avoid this void so it is optional so
that means if there is no return type
that is called this function does not
return anything so let's define a
variable so I type for first name and
here I assigned my name Mohamed and then
suppose I want to define another
variable last name so in this case I
will type string last name asan and now
I want to print this so first name then
last name so if I here I have to put a
plus sign for string concatenation and
if I want to run this program I have to
type dot playground
TRT Harry here you will see the output
Mohamed is space asan so what does it
happen in here so the first line number
two here I define a variable is in the
VAR keyword so var means a variable and
the variable name is first name what I
have assigned Mohammed as the failure so
when you define a variable like this way
dart compiler automatically gets that
this is a string type very values
because and this is called type in for
inference and in the second type a
second line the third line we define the
variable as easting type and which we
mentioned it in the before so if you
defined a variable like this way that is
string last then you cannot assign other
vidoes like if i type two it will show
an error but in the first case if I type
two here it will not show an Iran in
here because in that case it will
understand that this is a integer value
so you have to remember this thing in
dart programming language that it
supports both type inference and is
statically typed defined so when we type
dark playground or DRT there is just in
time compilation happens so this code
will compile on the fly and then it will
run and we can see the output in that
terminal if there will be an erode we
can see that error also in here
another thing is that all the built-in
dart libraries like a built-in types
collection and other poor functionality
for every dot program basically is
defined in a package that is called dart
door Pullen core package so if you want
to import you have to type this the
import then single quote dot : then core
package but the thing is that if I run
this program again nothing will be
changed
it will run as usual but the thing is
that this dart colon core package
automatically imported so for these case
or normal cases we do not need to import
this dot colon core pack is it will be
imported in every dart program autumn
ethically so let's write another program
in this program we want to take input
from users so for this input output
operation we have to import a library
that is called IO libraries so I have to
import then dart : io and now let's
write a main function and here I want to
first show user that you have to type
your name so I I have to write a code
like it standard out dot write line and
here I will write what is your name and
then a question mark and then I will
take the input from user so for this
reason I will type string name and then
standard in dot read line sync and then
I will print that name so my name is
dollar name so let's run this program
first so you see in this condition what
is your name if I type mode ASSA you
will be seeing that it is showing my
name is Mohammad Ahsan so basically this
is standard out and is standard in this
library is defined in this dart : io
package so the first line we are showing
you that that by writing standard out
dot write line that means it this line
is shown in the terminal then in this
line is standard in dot read lancing
this when at the program found this line
it will wait for the user to give an
input so when we get the input from user
we assign that variable which is a
string in this named variable and
finally we just using the built-in print
method or print function to output the
name in the terminal and here you will
see in within the estream we are using a
dollar sign and the variable name so
this is called a sting interpolation so
within the easting we change a variable
with the real value we can write common
in Treece
/ a boy in dark tip in a dart program so
if you want to write a comment in line
then you have to use two forward slash
that is called inline comment if you
want to write block comment then you
have to use forward slash star and you
have to in the common using another is
turn forward slash so here we can write
multiple line of comment and another
comment is three forward slit is called
documentation so that will be used as a
document for your program
[Music]
there are two type programming language
one is called strongly typed another is
called dynamic type so in strongly typed
programming language like C++ Jabbar
sweep the type of a variable is known at
compile time and another type
programming language that is called
dynamic type like Python Ruby or
JavaScript in these programming
languages the type of a variable is
known at runtime so in dart programming
language there are five basic type like
int double string Bowl and dynamic this
fourth type are fundamental type and
dynamic is a dynamic type that means we
can change the value at runtime with
different type values so in this example
let's define a variable so int for
integer amount 1 is the variable name
where we have s and 100 then in the
second line we have defined var amount
to 200 so in this case the by using the
VAR keyword we define a variable amount
2 so L it is 200 that is an integer
value so the dart compiler automatically
knowns knows that that this is a integer
value and integer variable so dart
compiler make this amount to an integer
so next time if we SN other value like
double or sting in this amount o it will
shown an ero and the third line we have
just been this amount 1 and amount 2
then we define another variable using
double and put a double value and then
in the second cases we have defined the
double variable but using the VAR
keyword so the variable value type will
be determined at the compile time then
you also print that value as well then
we define another variable name 1 which
is a string type we define in by
mentioning string and in that second
cases we using we define name to a
distinct variable using VAR cured but
here the type inference occurred here we
define
easy true 1 using the bull key or that
is a boolean type variable where we have
assigned true this is a boolean value
and then using the Warka we define
another variable is it true to where we
define false video which is also a
boolean value so both of these variable
are boolean type and finally we define a
variable weight variable and where we
have used our key we use the keyword
dynamic so this week variable is a
dynamic type variable so the value value
type can be defined at the rendezvous at
the first time we have assign 100 and
the second type we have assigned dart
programming which is a history and the
first time it was a integer so let's run
this program we see that this program is
run perfectly well so here we see that
amount 1 100 amount to 200 this line
this pin line is printed in here then we
printed the floating point values using
this line print so we are seeing that
these values is also painted correctly
here we are using this my name is this
thing is also painted in here and we can
see this true and fall this two variable
the boolean type variable values are
also painted in here perfectly well and
finally this dynamic type week variable
which we have SN 100 it is printed in
here and the next time we change the
value of this week variable as string
type ways we have seen that this is also
printing correctly that means this week
variable which is dynamic type we can
assign any type of value at any time so
this is the prim fundamental or
primitive type in dart programming
language and one thing you have to
remember the dart is an object-oriented
programming language and everything is
object in here even the null type so now
that means if we assign here week
variable and just put now that means
there is nothing and if I just type
print week variable in this case and
let's try to run this program and you
see it is showing now so even this null
type is also an object so everything is
object in dart programming
where this integer value this variable
everything is object even this function
is also an object which is a subtype of
the function class
[Music]
we can define a string variable using
single quote or double quotes so if you
start defining a string using single
core you have to in that easting using
single code as well the same rule is
applied for double quotes as well so
here is one is define a string variable
using single quote and h2 is define
using double quote in the s3 variable we
using a single quote and we also want
that there is an apostrophe within the
each keyword so in this case we have to
use a backward slash to separate this
single code within the string but if we
are just using this double core to
define a system we can just replace this
special character by just single code
and finally if you want to define a
Royston roistering mean if there is a
special character that is newline
character suppose it will not be
evaluated so to define a roy string you
have to just put a are in front of the
string so let's run this program you see
the single quote this string is printed
double chorus ting is also printed and
here it's you see that this apostrophe
is showing here nicely also for the s4
variable as well and in the final case
our Royce ting you see this newline
character is not evaluated because it is
defined as Royston by using the R in
front of the string string interpolation
means to replace a variables value
actual value within a string so here we
have defined a variable age where we
have assigned 35 an integer value and in
the second string variable we replace
this age a variables value within the e
string by using this dollar sign so that
means when you want to interpolate in a
easting just use the dollar sign in
front of the variable name within a
string so if we run this program we see
the output is showing correctly that my
age is 35 we can define multi-line
string in dart programming language
using either three single quotes and
ending with three single cores or is
starting with three double quotes and
ending with three double course if
run this program you see it issuing the
multi-line string in the terminal type
conversion is a very important topic in
any programming language sometimes we we
need to convert an e string to an
integer and sometimes we need to convert
an integer to string to convert an e
string to an integer value you can use
the parse method of int objects so here
we are passing and string one and this
method part will convert this string one
to an integer one and assign that value
in this one variable in the next line we
are using the built-in a search function
to verify that so here we are verifying
that if one equal to integer one if it
is not true then it will show an ero in
the terminal similarly if we want to
convert an E string to double we can use
the parse method defined in that double
object so let's run this program you see
there is no problem no erode issuing
that means this parsing or cut correctly
but if we want to change the easting
like this string there is known no
integer value within this string then
what happened let's write this program
you see it is showing an ero that this
parse method try to convert this easting
to an radix 10 number but it is it found
that there is STR character so that
means it cannot convert this STR to an
integer value there so it will be thrown
an e roll and this exception is called
format exception so you have to make
sure that if you want to convert an
integer or double value string value to
an integer or double primitive value
then you have that easting with that
integer or double value similarly if we
want to convert from integer to e string
we can use that here 1.2 string method
so that means as I said before that
every
thing in dart programming language is an
object so that means here the new
Merrillville one is also an object so we
can use this to string method of that
object so here we are typing 1.2 string
and we are converting this integer value
to an e string value and assign this in
one an E string variable and in later we
also using this pi values that is double
value to a string so here we have to use
two e string as fixed two so here
basically we want to convert this for
floating point number two to fixed point
floating point numbers so let's run this
program and you see there is no error so
that means this one integer is converted
to as easting which we are verifying in
here by putting single quote outside of
one that means it's an e string and it
asserted correctly similarly here we
converted this double value to two fixed
point double string so and we are
verifying here that if this is as string
with two fixed point
fixed point number and we found that yes
it is also asserted correctly in here so
that means three point one point four
now is in string value so this is how we
can convert any type to any type in dart
programming language when we define a
variable we can define that variable as
a constant type that means during the
run then we cannot change the value of
that variable so to define a variable as
constant in dart programming language we
have to use the keyword Const so here we
have defined a variable a constant and
this is an integer constant because
there I have put a zero with an integer
so by type inference the compiler will
make this variable as integer constant
similarly a countable is a boolean
constraint and a consisting is an in
this string constant then we are
printing these three very
and also the next three line we are
checking the runtime type that means
what type the compiled created during
the runtime so let's around this program
you see where we are seeing zero true a
cons string and the type is int bool and
easting so this is how we can define
constant type in dart programming
language
suppose we defined a variable like int
and Nam and did not assign any value
within this variable if we just use the
print function and try to print the
value of this norm variable let's run
this program and see what is shown in
the terminal it is showing that there is
null that means there is no value
assigned in this variable so you have to
keep in mind that if you define a
variable or object but did not assign
any very values on it that means that
then empty so it is it contains the null
object we can also externally use null
in this case so if I run this program
again you see there is no change so that
means if we did not explicitly assign
null value within a variable it
automatically assigned if there is no
real value assigned to this variable
[Music]
if you know other programming language
like JavaScript C++ Swift or Python all
the standard operators will work in dart
programming language so for example if
you want to add two videos you can just
use the plus sign for negative - you can
use minus sign for if you want to see
that if there is any reminder or not you
can use the modulus operator that is
also called percentage operator in some
programming language and if you want to
check relational video like if two
values are equal or not love for example
here using this if logic we are checking
that if num equal to zero or not then
print zero for not equal to you can use
not equal to this operator and for
greater than or equal to you can use
this greater than an equal sign and less
than an equals and for less than or
equal to operator
if you want to use in short of a
shortcut value like for example if for
here we are using num multiplication
equal to 2 it means that I want to
assign nom equal to num multiplied by 2
for example here we are using this
shortcut 0 so we put this multiplication
value in here in front of the equal sign
and and then we are passing 2 that means
this is num equal to num x 2 similar t
thing you can use using the plus minus
like that and a dot programming language
also supports unary operator that means
you can if you use C++ Java or
JavaScript you can use this even Aereo /
- like + + num just means that increment
nom value one by one you can this is
called post in cream a pre increment and
this is called post in khammam post
increment both are unary operator and
you can also use another shortcut video
like plus equal 1 similar similar to
this in re operator and for logical
operator you can use this double
ampersand sign so that means this
logical and and for logical order you
can use this double
bar sign so in Python we use this we use
only n and or the the physical the
English cure like n and and and or in
Python but in JavaScript in dart we can
use this logical and and logical or
operator to make two condition bills in
within an if statement so here we are
writing a code like if num greater than
200 and nom less than 200 3 then print
200 - 200 - so the here we can use the
logical and operator and in this case
both of this part and this part should
be true to make this thing happen for
not equal to operator we can just use
this sign and then equal sign so if I
run this program you see everything is
showing currently in the terminal null
our operator is one of the important
operator in dart programming language
basically this kind of operator is
existed in many modern programming
languages like Swift cortland and in
dirt there are three variation of this
operator so let's discuss so suppose we
want to define a class so in this class
nom there is a property we declare that
is another num and where we have
assigned 10 and let's define the main
function so here I want to create an
object of this class num so far in equal
to no so to create object of a class in
dart programming language you just have
to use the class them and the
parentheses then the object will be
automatically created so an instance of
this num class is created and SN in this
variable that is n so n is an object of
norm class let us define another
variable so what we actually want we
want to assign this value in this number
variable suppose this kind of value
comes from another
area suppose we are using an API from
this API we get this kind of a JSON
object and the JSON object maybe they
are exists available and we want to get
that number so we have to make sure that
this in object is not null so how we do
that normally what we write if in not
equal to null then number equal to n dot
num and just print the number so
normally it's a common programming
practice that we check that if the
object is not now then Excel the object
properties like it here so if I run this
program dart playground you see it is
working perfectly
suppose this an object is not we remove
this num last name and if I run this
program again you see it is showing this
number has a null object so there is
nothing basically when this n object is
now this thing will not Excel but if I
just remove this F word and if I run
this program again you see now there is
an error thrown that is no such method
either so basically we are excesses in
dot num but n is now that's why it will
thrown an error and the program will
terminate in here so there is a shortcut
in a dart programming language language
using that we can avert this if
statement so what we have to write we
just have to write instead of n dot num
we have to write in a question mark then
door then num so if I run this program
again you see in this case it is showing
nothing because there is no n object in
object is now that's why this thing is
not work and number equals now that is
shown in here and if there is an object
suppose we put in the we create an
object in here the instance of num class
and if I run this program again you see
now it is showing tin so the number is
10 so basically this null our operator
means that if there is an object so if n
is an object and if the object property
naam is accessible then just do it so
that means if n is an object and if n is
an valid object then excess the property
named num and assign the value from num
to here but if the N is not an object if
n is a null object then just escape this
there is another variation of this null
operator so in case if this n is not
a valid object there there is nothing
happen in here right the number will
remain null as it is defined but what we
want if the aim object is null we want a
default value help to be s any number so
how we can do that the shortcut way to
do that is you use a double question
mark and assign a default value for
example we want to default values 0 so
let's save this program and run again so
now you see that when we run this
program the number is printing as 0 that
means when this part is null then this
part will be executed but if we just
again put this num here and if I run
this program again then you see that 10
is printed so that means now N is a
valid object that has a property of num
so that value is SN in here but in case
n is a is not a valid object then in
that case the default video 0 will be as
an in number the third variation of this
knowledge operator is like this suppose
we define a variable number now it is
not if I just print this number and save
this program and run you see it issuing
null but what we want that we want to
make a condition like if the variable or
object is null we want to assign a
default value so what we can do that we
just use double question mark then a
equals sign all together and put a
default value if I run this program
again you see now it is showing 100 if I
run this program after the first print
statement you see the number 100 is
showing in the second case as well so
here it is happening is that the when
the number is not a valid object that
means the number is now then this 100
will be assigned in this variable and
that is permanent ok so you have to keep
in keep mine
in this Chi variation of the nollie or
operator because if you do not check now
sometimes your program may care so if
you know this not a reporter and you can
if you can use it wisely then it can
save in many cases in your program
there is another operator called ternary
operator in JavaScript C C++ Java so
that opera is also existed in dart
programming language so for example here
we define a program int x equals 100 and
var result equals x reminder to equal to
0 so that means if we want to define
this 100 I mean the value of x by 2 so
if there is any reminder and if that
remainder is 0 then pin this event but
if the remainder is not 0 then print or
so in the next time we are printing the
result so if I run this program you see
in this case it is printing even because
x equals 100 which is devided which is
reminded by 2 and there is no remainder
so that means this condition made and
the first part of the of this ternary
operator is executed but if I just make
it suppose 101 and run this program
again you see now this condition is not
met that's why this odd is printed there
is a type test operator in dart
programming language for example let's
define a variable integer X equal 100 or
maybe var X equal 100 so we want to know
that if what if X is an integer type
then just pin something so how we can
write that program so we have to type if
then X is int then print integer
so let's save this program and run you
see if this condition is true that means
we want to check that whether the
variable of X is integer type that's why
we have written that if X is in that
means if X is an integer then print in
design and it is true but if we change
the value to suppose a double value and
if I run this program again then this
condition is not true that's why we did
not see any integer is printed in the
terminal sometimes we want to write a
program with some condition that means
if a certain condition is true then do
something and if certain condition is
false then don't do something so in a
dart programming language we can write
conditional code using if else if and
else operator so that means here let's
define a program first we define a
variable into the number equals 100 so
then we are using the remainder operator
we are checking that if this condition
is true that means if this number is
divided by 2 with no dividend that means
equal to 0 then print even if not then
if it is divided by 3 then print odd and
E in other cases that means if this
first condition is not true second
condition is not to the default cases
then pilled confused so let's run this
program first so here it is showing even
then I am I put here 90 and it is
showing even again so if I put here 91
it is showing confused so in this
scenario the first condition when made
then the second and third condition that
means yourself and each block will not
be executed but if this block is not
true then the then the program will
check this block if it is not true then
it will check the default block so this
is how we can write a fields if
and it's condition in that program there
is another way we can write if is a
statement in dart programming language
and in this case we we have to use the
switch statement
so basically switch works similar like
if-else condition so here we are
defining a variable number where we have
SN way to 0 and then in the switch
statement within the parentheses we are
checking this number variable and within
the curly braces this is the body of the
switch statement we are checking that if
the value of this variable E is 0 then
print this and break then break from
this switch statement in case this
condition is not true then check this
condition if case equals 1 then do this
thing and break from the switch
statement if no none of the case is true
then just a do the default condition so
here let's run this program it is
showing even because this condition made
so if I put here one and save this
program and run you see now it is
showing or because this condition is not
made that's why this condition made
that's why it is showing here but in
case if I put different pedal and run
this program
it is showing confuse because 0 and 1 is
not made this condition is not mean
that's why the default condition is
executed looping means we want to
execute a task for a finite number of
time repeatedly so there are basically
five kinds of dope in dart programming
language so the first loop is the
standard for loop is 10.4 dough it's
similar like in JavaScript so for
example we want to print one to ten mmm
so how we can do that let's write F is
standard for loop so you have to pass by
four then within parenthesis let's
declare a variable var I equals 1 then
semicolon this is the first part that
are initialized part then we write the
condition I there is in equals to 10 so
as long as I list they're not equals to
tame then run this loop and then the
increment or decrement part so here I
have written pre increment plus plus I
so these are the increment or decrement
/ so that means and the wind ax this
program is run this part will be
executed first then it will check the
condition in here and after and then the
body will be executed then the program
goes to here and increment the value of
I and then check the condition again if
the condition is true then it will break
from the loop otherwise it will continue
the loop so if I just put print I and
run this program you see it is showing 1
to 10 so this is the standard for loop
there is another for loop that is called
for in loop suppose we have an array so
far numbers we define a variable number
and using the square bracket it is a
shortcut that means it's an array we
define some videos within this array 1 2
3 and we want to print all of this video
so using for in loop we can do it easily
so here we are writing for then var in
in numbers and within the body print and
so here it is meaning that for part in
in number so the value of n will be
first time 1 second time - and third
time 3 it will be executed as long as
the array contains some pillows so if I
run this program you see this wing 1 2 3
so this is the standard for in loop if
we want to use this array using the
standard follow we can do that also for
example for VAR I equals 0 I less then
numbers dot length then plus plus I and
here print numbers I
so if I run this program you see in this
case one two threes again printed
because we are using the standard four
loop there is another loop that is
called for each loop so basically for
each n higher order function so for
example here like before we have defined
an array with and some integer values so
we want to print that each of this video
right so we can do that using numbers
dot for each and then here we have to
define a function so for example we want
to access each of these video right so
we can do that like in and then we can
use an arrow function what is the arrow
function I will discuss later we can
also use a normal function here as well
but in this case it looks elegant too is
error function and we just write code
like this way if I run this program
again you see it is showing or sorry
here I have the I did a mistake it have
to be it has to be in so if I run this
program you see one two three is
printing so basically this for each is
an higher-order function because it
takes another function as parameter this
full thing is actually a function but we
have written in the short from that is
called arrow function I will discuss
this thing in later in the functional
part but just keep in mind that there is
another way for looping especially in
array or object using the for each loop
if you think this arrow function looks a
bit complicated for you you can do
another thing you can define another
function like world print num and here
is a parameter and just print this num
and now instead of this arrow function
just past this Nam function print down
function reference and if I run this
program again
you see the same output one two three
basically we are passing this function
as a parameter of this for each
higher-order function there is another
loop or the number four types of loop is
called while loop suppose we have
defined a variable name equals five and
we want to print the value of num unless
it is zero so we have to write while
then the condition within parenthesis
that Nam get at this zero so as long as
num greater than zero executes the body
and then we first printing the value of
now and then we decrease the value of
num by one if I run this program you see
it is showing nothing because I did not
save so let's run again then you see
that it is showing five four three two
one
there is another variation of this while
loop so instead of using the condition
before we have to write do in here and
after the body caller basis you can
write the condition the while condition
after this curly braces so if I run this
program again you see the same output
five four three two one if within a loop
for a certain condition we want to
terminate the loop we can do this do
this by using break statements so here
in this loop this loop will run ten
times but here we have written a
condition if I greater than five then
just break otherwise print I if I run
this program you see zero to five is
printed and then when the value of I
becomes C that is the it is greater than
5 then this break statement executed and
the loop is terminated so this is how we
can use break current break statement in
any loop to terminate the loop suppose
we want to write a program to print the
odd numbers or even number so in our
case we want to print the odd number
so we have written a loop I a standard
for loop this loop will run 110 times
and here we have written a condition if
I modulus 2 equal to 0 that means if the
DV after the division if there is no
remainder that means 0 then continue
here continuous statement means that
don't go the remaining statement just
continue from the loop from here if I
run this program you see it is showing
the odd numbers from the range 0 to 10
so here you have seen that 1 3 5 7 9 so
the first time I equals 0 and 0 less
than 10 so 0 remainder 2 equal to 0
there so this condition made true so the
continue statement executed and the and
the loop goes to here so I becomes 1 and
then the condition is again checking if
as 1 is less than 10 and within the body
if one remind that 2 equal to 0 it is
not true that's why this condition did
did not meet for the second time that's
why we have seen this one is printing in
here so this is how this container is
statement wash within a for loop
[Music]
there are three building collection type
in dart programming language least sate
and map so list basically is an ordered
collection of hellos so it is in some
programming language is called array but
in dart programming language it is
called list so suppose we want to define
a list and we can do that using list
class so when we define list L is T and
then we define a variable so that means
this names is an object of list class
and here using the shortcut way that is
means using the square bracket we can
define somewhere like Jack and Jill so
these two are string items within this
list so if we want to access each of
this video we can do that so basically
in list the first item is indexed in 0
the second item is 1 and this is how it
goes so if I want to access the first
item from this list we have to write
print names then square bracket 0
if I run this program you see it is
showing Jack because Jack is instead
within the position or index at zero if
I print one and run the program again in
this case it is showing until if we want
to know the number of element existing
in the list we can use the length
property of the list object so here we
are printing name dot length so let's
run the program you see it is showing
two that means this list object names
contains two items instead of lists if I
just put the heart here and if I run
this program you see it what in this
case the compiler by type inference will
know that this names list is a string
type list item so if I put my cursor in
here you see it issuing list angle
bracket string that means this
names is a risk and it is known in by
that type inference if we want to access
each of this item we can do that by
using any for loop but normally in this
case you can use the for in loop so for
bar in in names and print in so if I run
this program you see Jack and Jill is
printed if I want to use mixed item that
means some videos will be seeing some
hello may be double some videos may be
integer we can do that as well so 10 100
point 1 and if I run this program you
see each of this value is printed and if
I put my cursor in here you see now it
is showing list and with an angle
butthead object but if we want that this
leash should be a string type we can do
that by defining the in strip lacing
this bar by list and within angle
bracket we define is string in that case
if you put any value other than is thing
it will shown an arrow so this is a
statically typed names list that means
you cannot put other type instead of in
string if I run this program you see it
is showing out Jack and Jill so for
statically typed list you can just put a
angle bracket after the keyword list and
put the type in here this list is a
mutable type so that means if we want to
change the value of the index 1 we can
do that so names 1 instead of 0 we type
like a mark and if I run this program
you see now it is showing Jack and mark
so the value is replaced with a new
fellow
but if we want to define each of these
value is constant that means we do not
want to change it at run time we can do
that easily by just putting the Const
keyword before the square bracket if I
use this program now and run you see it
is showing an eroded unsupported
operation because you cannot change a
constant value at run time if I remove
this part clear the skin and run the
program again you see there is no error
in that case suppose we want to copy a
list to a another list mmm we can how we
can do that for example let's define
another list or just a VAR names to and
if I just assign these names one I'm in
this next part and if we accept this
name stew and run this program you see
we can still accept the value Jack and
Jill but basically when you assign a
object like list within another object
it's actually not copied instead these
names to accessing the names value so
suppose if I change the value of names
after I selling this suppose I change
the value of names 1 equal to mark and
if I run this program again you see we
get that updated value we are changing
that value repels the value of jail by
mark in the nails variable and we are
looping the names to variable but we can
still see this updated view like Jack
and Martha this is not East election
this is not actually copying rather both
names too and names pointing the same
list of items so instead of doing that
if we want to really clone the list hot
we can do that using our spread operator
in dart 2.3 we can do that easily so
here we just put a square bracket and
then 3 dot and then the first variable
name so names 1 so if I just run this
program again you see in this case when
we looping names too
we are actually getting the old value
Jack and Jill basically in this case
names 2 and names does not point to the
same list of item
both names and names two are totally
different items list items so this
spread operator is similar like
JavaScript I first saw this three dot
spread of water in JavaScript and this
three daughters pet operator is
introduced in dart 2.3
set in dart programming language is an
unordered collection of unique items and
dart support for set is provided by set
literals and the set type so suppose we
defining is said by var keyword var
hello chance and here we have to use the
curly braces and within curly braces we
want to put some string value so we can
type flow Rhine and then chloride to V
Rose so these are basically
unique items if I copied this Florin
again after the comma and if I loop this
program so for VAR x in hello chains and
print X
and if I run this program you see it is
only showing Flores fluorine and
chlorine
so this fluorine if we put it two times
but it is actually stored one time
because by definition set is an unique
collection of items there is another way
to define set if you want to define an
empty set you cannot just put like this
suppose we want to put an empty set hmm
just remove this for loop and remove
these curly braces the items of this
color basis if I just type print hello
jeans run time type and if I run this
program you see in these cases we
thought that it should be set but
instead it become a lint hash map type
hmm so if you want to define a empty set
if you want to define an empty set you
must have to define the type time in
here like you have to put if I just put
a string here with an angle bracket now
you see it is showing has said so just
empty curly braces means hash map but
when you are define a type before the
caliber then it did become a hash set
and another way to define hash set is
like this that using the set key word
that means set class is in the set class
then you can also put this string thing
in here say it string and then if I put
in names and curly braces and if I check
the names runtime type you see it is
also headed so either way you can define
an empty has set in dart programming
language in that programming language
map basically is a collection of
key-value pair of items in some
programming language like in Python
it is called dictionary so let's define
a map in dart programming language so
here I have defined F map gift and the
key of each of the item is a string so
here I have defined within single quote
fast which by this key we are putting
value petrus then say again tart laughs
and filled golden links if I want to
access each of this item we can do that
easily like print gifts and this is also
an ordered and if we want to access any
of this value we have to use the key so
for example here I am I want to use the
key fifth and if I run this program you
see it is showing golden rings so this
is how we can create map in that
programming language another thing is
that you can also use integer value SK
for example to one tree and in this case
we also remove this fifth and instead we
just put one and run this program you
say you see that it also works without
any issue if you want to define an empty
set
sorry if you want to define an empty map
you can do that using the map class so
here we are defining gift as aim and we
want to the created an instance of map
in here and SN in the gifts and now we
want to add key value pairs by ourself
we can do that by easily like gifts then
within square bracket we can put the key
suppose here first as a key and the
value of suppose mango and if I run this
program gives fast
you see it works so this is how we can
create a map in that programming
language another way we can do that
using a curly braces and in there we
have to put the key and the Velo
together for example here fast
and within after : we have to put like
mango the Velo then another key
so this basically key and this is the
video so this 2 item becomes a key will
appear as a one item within the map so
in the second key we want to put another
video like jackfruit and now we want if
we want to access any of this video like
gifts second and if I run this program
you see it is showing jackfruit so this
is how we can create a map in that
programming language in dart programming
language each function is an object of
class function where F is the capital
later so let's define a function for
example we want to defining a function
as a square which we can use to e Square
any integer or num type any integer or
double value so for this reason we want
the return type should be dynamic so
when you define a function at the first
first part you have to define that type
which it will return if there is this if
a function does not return anything you
can use void or you can escape the void
which means it does not return anything
so in this case we are putting dynamic
then the function name is square we also
take any hello so this function can take
parameter so if we want to if you want
that a function take parameter we have
to define there so here we are defining
part number this function will take a
parameter as num and this function will
return the naam into num so whatever we
pass any valid integer or double value
in this square function it will multiply
that by
the same value and return the value so
let's define another function for
example what show output and here we
take an a define a variable as parameter
of our message so this function takes
message as parameter and using the
built-in print function it will pin the
messages in the terminal
so now let's call this function first
show output and within this function we
want to use this function square so here
we are typing Square where we are
putting 2 if I run this program you see
it is showing 4 then we use the same
statement but in this case we are
putting to 0.5 and just run this program
you see now it is showing four and 6.25
as we define this function this a square
function as dynamic so that means this
function can return any type of num
value like any type of integer or double
value and another thing if I just type
print and square this function name we
without parenthesis and runtime runtime
type and let's run this program you see
this is showing there this function
square is a dynamic type in dart
programming language there is a shortcut
way to defining a function which is a
one-line statement so for example here
in dart programming language you have to
use the equal sign and greater than sign
together to make a arrow this is called
fat arrow and sometimes called fat arrow
expression so here we define a full
function write the dynamic square Varnum
and within curly braces we define a body
we can make it we can make it shorter
using arrow function so instead of this
just remove this arrow part
and return part and just put a arrow
here so here what we are defining that
dynamic square Varnum then arrow
expression now multiply numb so when you
write an arrow function like this way
the result of the value after the
competition will automatically return so
if I save this program and run again you
see this program works as like before a
function that has no name or in short
you can call nameless function is called
anonymous function in dart programming
language in some other programming
language like in Python it is called
lambda or in some programming language
it is called closer so here let's define
a list with some string values of I TM
and we want to use the for each function
of this list so let's type list dot for
each this is a higher-order function
because for each function cat can take
other function as parameters within the
body we will define a anonymous
functions of before defining anonymous
function in here less definite named
functions so suppose I am defining a
function void print F which take a
parameter item and just using the print
built-in function it just print the
value of the item variable in the screen
and here we just want to pass this
printf function as reference so if I run
this program you see it issuing Apple
bananas and orange but in this case or
sometimes when you define a forest
function with a shorthand function then
in many cases computer programmers do
not define a named function instead they
prefer to use anonymous function within
the places so to do that let's carve
this part
and remove the named function part and
here remove this printf and put that
thing in here
so if I save this program clear the
screen and run the program again you see
it works so that means this function is
an anonymous function because this
function does not have any name there
are two types of parameters in function
in dart programming language like Python
programming language so one type of
parameter is called positional parameter
or positional argument and the second
type is called named parameter or named
argument so let's see the positional
argument or positional parameters first
so here we are defining an arrow
function which takes two parameter so in
this case we are using the positional
arguments so here num1 is the first
position number the second third
position and we just returning after
combining the value if I run this
program you see it worse it is showing
for now here if you look carefully you
see that when we call this some method
we just passing the value and we expect
that this 2 will be assigned in num1 and
these two will be a zani num2 because we
are using the positional argument on or
positional parameter let's convert this
function this error function to named
parameters so in that case we have to
use the curly braces here so we want
that this 2 parameter should be as named
parameter and when I put curly braces in
here you see it is showing red color in
here so if I just remove this theme and
if I call some now you see that it is
showing num1 and num2 if I put num for
example in this case if I want to put
num2 fast so I have right written num2
colon then suppose for
then I want to put naam one supposed to
if I save this program and run this
again you see it is showing six so when
you are using named parameter you have
to use the name of the parameter when
you are calling the function and this
basically works for not only arrow
function but also for a general function
another interesting thing of name
parameter is that by default named
parameter is optional and we can also
mix positional parameter and named
parameter together for example in this
case we want to change a bit we want
that the num2 is only named parameter
but the Nam one is positional parameter
and num2 may be optional right so in
this case when we want to call this
function sum then we have to put the
value as the first parameter suppose I
am putting tin and as this name
parameter for this name parameter I used
the name num2 and suppose i put two and
if i run this program you see it is
showing 12 but i told before that when
you define a variable sorry when you
define the parameter as named parameter
by default that is optional that means
if you do not provide any value for num2
it should work right but it is crashing
why we defining this num2 parameter as
optional by defining this as a named
parameter but when there is no value but
we are still accessing this value so as
this num2 may be optional what we can do
we can write a conditional nah-nah our
operator like double : 0 so if I if I
change this modification in here and if
I run this program again
you see it is also showing and erode
because I think I have to put a
parenthesis to give the priority and now
if I run this program again you see
there is no error so in this case when
we do not provide the named parameter
value and in the function body we are
checking that whether num2 is null or
not if it is now then just past the
default value as 0 otherwise if there is
any value just used there so if I again
use this statement print and some and
here I put another value 10 2 and num2
so you see it is showing 10 and 12 if
you want that if no value is provided we
can use any default value so instead of
using this we can do a shortcut default
value parameter so here after Nam - we
put a equal sign and put a default value
so if we change this function here and
if I run this program again you see
there is no error because when there is
no parameter no value for num2 parameter
it is using the 0 in here so 0 + 10 that
is 10 and when we pass any value like 2
then in this case the default value will
not be used and 10 + 2 will be 12 so
this is showing in here I told that by
definition name parameter are optional
right but if you are using a positional
parameter and you want to make any of
them as optional then how you can do
that so for example here we want to make
this numbers optional but this is a
positional argument or positional
parameter so to make it optional we just
have to put a square bracket outside of
the parameter and now this num to become
optional so if I run this program
you see it issuing for n2 said the first
time we are passing two values and the
second time we are passing one value so
in that case that nom to become null and
here as we are using null our operator
so that default value zero will be used
in the second case
[Music]
in object-oriented programming class is
a very important topic using class we
can define our own custom type we can
encapsulate the related values and
related methods together and when you
define a class you can inherit to make
some subclass also you can do some other
thing like you can use polymorphism you
can reuse your object-oriented code for
other purpose so in dart programming
language we can create a custom type
using the class keyword so let's define
a class so here we are defining a class
named person so to define a class in
dirt you have to use the keyword class
then the class name and within curly
braces we are defining the body
so basically class is a blueprint for an
actual object this is not object this is
we are defining the type that means we
are defining a person class or person
type and later in the main function we
will use the object of this person class
so in this person class or blueprint we
want that a person should have a name a
person should have a is just basic to
type ok and now let's define a method in
here so when you define a function
within a cloud that is called method so
here we are defining a method void this
function or this method returns nothing
and then show output of function name
which is called method M in the context
of class and this method does not take
any parameter and it just print the
value of name and age
and now let's create an object so here
we can create object into oil of suppose
we want to use this person name in here
so person class name in here and then
person 1 and then person so when you
use the parentheses after the class name
basically it will instantiate an object
and assign that object to this person
one object variable right so if I just
want to excel this show output method I
can write person 1 dot show output
basically it will print nothing I mean -
now if we want to exist this variable
name and age we can do that like person
1 dot name suppose my name Muhammad and
person 1 dot H my suppose 35 so if I run
this program again it is showing
Muhammad and 35 now let's create another
person object but before that we want to
use a constructor which is called
default constructor so what is that so
let's define a constructor
so basically constructor is also a
method without any return type so an in
dart programming language you have to
use the class name as constructor name
so here we are want to defining a
constructor and constructor method is
automatically automatically called when
you instantiate an object so here in
this case we want to pass two parameter
is string name and the second parameter
is optional int age and by default it
should be 18 if there is no age is
provided and as this name parameter name
and the class properties name are same -
if you want to accept the objects or
instance of field we in this case we
have to use the disc keyword
this means this objects name or this
object is also we can call this using
this we can also call the method define
within the class so here we want to use
this dot name equals name and this dot
is equals a so if any name
age is provided when we create the
instance of a class we'll pass the
values and the village will be assigned
the object or instance fields so now
when we define the constructor you see
now it is showing an error because it
expect that I have to pass at least one
name so here I just passed suppose
Mohammed and after saving the program if
I run this program if sedition Mahmoud
and 18 because I did not pass any age
that's why it is taking that default
value but if I pass any as like 35
you see now addition mama
35 so this is called default constructor
another shortcut way to write a
constructor basically constructor is
using to assign some values when the
class instance is created if the
parameter name is same as the properties
or fields name within the class we can
use the shortcut oiseau instead using
this body we can just use here this dot
name and here these dot is and a default
value so if I run this program again you
see it works and in case if I do not
want to provide this 35 and run this
program again you see it works again it
is showing Mohammed 18 so if in your
constructor other than initializing the
values you want to do something is if
there is no other thing you want to do
with in the constructor body you can
skip that curly braces part and only use
this way to shortcut the constructor
let's define another object so in this
case I am going to using the VAR keyword
and person 2 and I give the person I
want to name check and the age is
suppose 25 and let's parse on 2 and call
the show output method
let's clear the screen Andreas from the
program you see in the Fosca it is
showing Mohammed 18 in the second case
it is showing jack 25 so basically this
person 1 and person 2 is totally
different instance of the same class
that is person class and here as we are
using var keyword but in the right side
after equals and we are using the person
class or using the type inference the
compiler the compiler will automatically
know that this person tool basically an
object of the person class other than
default constructor there is another
constructor that is called name
constructor so when you define a
constructor like this where like the
class name as the constructor then this
constructor will automatically that is
why it is called default constructor but
sometimes we may need to instantiate an
object of it as with some different
kinds of values right then how we can do
that there is another way suppose we
want to define a named constructor if
you defined other constructor beside the
default constructor that is called named
constructor to define a name caustically
you have to use the class name so here
person then you have to put a dot and
then the constructor name so we want to
name the constructor as guest and here
we want to assign some values so here
name equal to guest and H equal to 18
okay so let's create another object over
person three person and dot kissed in
this case you see I am NOT passing any
values that's why it is not calling that
default constructor instead it is I am
calling the guest constructor and if I
run this person 3 dot show output method
and run this program
you see in the tort cases it is showing
guests and 18 for the person 3 object so
this is how we can create other
constructor beside default constructor
normally what happened when we define a
variable either explicitly or within a
class we can change the value at any
time if we want right but if we want
that we will define a field or
properties or variable within a class
and that will be unchangeable after
initializing then we can do that by
using the final keyword so here we
define a class class X capital X and
within the class in the body we are
defining a variable named name so and we
are using the keyword final and then we
are defining another variable named age
where we have assigned tane and before
defining the variable we are using the
keyword aesthetic and cons so I will
discuss all of these three thing final
aesthetic and aesthetic Const and then
within the class default constructor we
are just assigning the value passing to
the constructor in the name variable so
let's create an object so far X x
capital F and then pass the value check
hmm and now if I print X dot name and
run this program you see it is swing
check so suppose I want to change the
value of name X dot name equals
something is like Jill and I want to
print the X dot name again
basically it is showing that name can be
used as a setter because it is final so
the dart extension in this visual is to
the code editor can detect that error
but if I just remove this final thing
and just use var name and
on this program you see first time it is
showing jet and the second time it is
showing G so the key point here is that
if you want to define any properties as
a constant you can use the final key
word and using the default constructor
when you assign their value you cannot
change the value after assigning it the
in the second time so only first time
you can assign the value using the
default constructor or any named
constructor
there is two why to define a value when
we defining a variable as constant one
is using final keyword another is using
cost keyword when you are using
concealer that is a compile time
constant it cannot be changed anytime at
or at runtime but when you are using
final keyword within a class you can
change it using the constructor so this
is possible at runtime and if you want
to use any Const constant video using
the constructor within a class you must
have to put a static in front of that
constant in front of that Const variable
so here we are using static cause in
test 10 and if I want to exist the value
of a we can write print X dot H and it
will not work because this is a
compile-time constant and we are using
is in the class and as this is a static
variable we have to use the custom to
access the property and this is called
class property this name is called
object property because this name is
different for different object but the
static property is same for all object
or all instance but that any backup
because it's a class property so here
you have to put the capital X dot age
and if I run this program you see it is
showing ten so suppose I want to create
another object for X suppose VAR y equal
to X and G and Y print
print why dot name and you see that 4x
object and y object the name value is
different but as this property is based
on class so we have to access that
property using the class name dot
property and this is same for all
instance so the age 10 is is same for
both X object and Y object if we want to
use the constant and final outside of
the class we can also do this so let's
remove this class part and remove this
thing and suppose we want to define two
constant videos so final of hard name
suppose the name is something mohamed
and in this case you do not have to use
the VAR because it is this name will be
be a string by type inference and let's
define another below-cost name suppose
age equal to 30 hmm let's print name and
print age and if I run this program
after clearing the terminal you see it
works and we cannot change any of this
name equal to something else cannot
possible also is equal to something
cannot possible it will be shooing and
erode because here you see it is showing
that name is a final variable and age is
also a constant variable which cannot be
reassigned and in this case outside of
the costs both final and constant
actually works like same there is no
difference so you can use anything in a
final or Const outside of the class when
we define a class and later we want to
add some extra feature within the class
but that extra feature is not required
for all the instance of the original
curve then we can use the class
inheritance and in dart program using
the extend keywords you can inherit a
class so here we are defining a class
vehicle where there is two property
modeling here and in the default
constructor we when we pass a model and
year in this default constructor we are
assigning that model value using this
dot model will be in this model and this
dot here the passing air will be as a
linear and within the default
constructor body we are just printing
the model enniaa nothing else and there
is another method Schwab put just it
print the model and here if we want to
use this here that's also okay basically
this means that the instance which it is
called now we are defining another class
class car and that inherit this vehicle
class right by using the extend keyword
and here we are defining a new property
that is called double price and in this
default constructor in the car
constructor what we I do we are taking
three parameter right is string the
string model here and this dot price
here here there is an interesting thing
so the interesting thing is that this
price is the new thing of this car but
disgust as inherit the vehicle so this
model and here also existed within the
car class so what we are doing we are
when we create an instance of this car
class we are assigning the price video
directly in this a variable using the DS
dot price but for the model and here we
want to pass that variable whose using
in the vehicle constructor and to do
that in that you have to use a colon
operator after the parentheses of the
sub class default constructor and you
have to use the super keyword and using
super keyword you have to pass the value
so here when we are calling this after
colonial calling the super then within
pass of the model and here this model
and here will be passed to this
constructor vehicle right so and in this
car cost we are also defining a method
show output and in the show output we
want to call this method that me
super cost method and here we are
calling this super keyword we are using
this super keyword then dot then the
method name so basically super dot schwa
truth means we are calling this method
the superclass method and then we are
printing the discours price now here we
are creating an object car 1 equals car
not vehicle object we are creating a car
one car object we are passing a code as
a model 2014 as the year and 150,000 as
the price and then we are calling car
won't show output so if I run this
program you see it is showing a code
2014 because when the instance of this
card is created then we are calling
basically this car constructor and here
we are passing through here right Accor
2014 and 150,000 so to a code will be in
here 2014 will be here positional
argument and 150,000 will be here and as
we are using this dot price and there is
a property named price as the same name
so this 150,000 will be assigned as the
price of this car and after : on the
default constructor as we are calling
super model here this according 2014
will be passed to this vehicle and will
be as in this model and a year and then
when we call this car one dot show
output you will see this method is
called here we are calling the super
method super cost method show output
where it will be printed model in here
so you see here more than year is
printed and then this price is printed
in here so we are seeing this price in
here so this is how we can our inherit
or extend a superclass to mean to a
subclass method overriding is suppose in
a plus there is a method and in the
subclass it here in Y class extend this
s class we want the same method to
redefine that is called method
overriding if you want that other
programmers know that this method is
overriding you can use add override
annotation so
when you use an override in front of a
method signature that means the compiler
will know that this method is overriding
and in any case there is no method of
the original name it will show an ear or
that method does not overwrite an
inherited method this is basically a
safety feature in dart programming
language when you overriding a method
you if you do not use the override
keyword it will not show an e role there
is no issue for this you have to use
override when you don't have control of
superclass method implementation
basically the intent of the override
notation is to case situation where a
superclass Trinian's a member and
independent subclass which used to
override the member could silently
continue working with the superclass
implementation so the good practice is
if you override a superclass method you
just use the add override annotation
Gators and setters are a special method
that provides read and write access to
an object properties normally each
instance variable has an implicit Gator
process setter if appropriate but if you
want you can create additional
properties by implementing getters and
setters using the gate and set keyword
so here we define a class rectangle
where we are using the NAM object so
basically num means it's an it's a type
and that that is inherited by the
integer and double type so here we are
defining num left top width and height
so the value of left of width and height
can be integer or double and in the
default constructor we are just
assigning the values passed and SN in
the properties now we are defining two
Gators that is right and bottom and two
setter for each of them so to defining a
Gator we are defining a right Gator name
right and use the gate keyword before
the name and then we are providing the
return type and here we are using an
arrow function and it with what it will
do if we
call this right Gator will get left plus
with these two variables data and will
get this value and if we want to make a
satyr we have to use the set keyword and
the setter name so here it is right and
we are passing any value number low and
we are putting the left value so using
the arrow function what we are doing we
are assigning left equals value - which
so we have a - we are passing a failure
right and what we are doing we are doing
a customization so we are we are a -
thing that with value from the value and
that assigning that value in the left
variable within that class similarly we
are doing the same thing as for bottom
and now we are creating an object rect
using the rectangle class name and
passing some values and then we're
printing the Reg dot left hello letter
on this program we are seeing that the
lab value is 3 and then we are par
calling the getter method that is right
so reg dot write equals 12 when we
defining a method we have to use the
parentheses but when we are using the
Gator or setter we do not need to use
any appearances like when we want to
access any Gator we just have to use the
dot operator and when we want to use a
sitter we just call the setter name and
the equal sign and in that case the
value will be assigned as a setter so
here when we are calling red dot right
equals to L so that 12 comes in here and
of hello - so value is 12 and it - we so
with is here that is 20 so value is 12
12 minus 20 equals minus H so that's why
when we are printing reg dot left we are
getting this minus 8 output so this is
how we can define getter and setter in
dart programming language
[Music]
exception handling is a feature in a
programming language by which we can
know that if there is any runtime
problem occurred or not
so in dirt if we want to use exception
handling we can use the throat try catch
finally keyboard so suppose here we are
defining a function must greater than
zero so this function if it gets the
value greater than zero then there is no
problem it will return the value but if
it gets a value equal to zero less than
0 then it will throw an exception and to
throw an exception you have to use the
throw keyword and the exception class
name and within the exception custom you
can provide a message you see the depth
of method definition is swinging and
showing above the cursor if a function
throws in exception you have to catch
that otherwise the program will
terminated so we're defining another
function let verify the value or where
we can pass any value and within the
function we are defining a value
verification variable where we'll SNF a
wasn't of value so as this math function
must greater than zero can throw an
exception so we have to define this
function within that try block so here
is in the try block we are using value
verification e equal mass greater than
zero and we are passing the value so if
there is an e roro card then we are just
printing the error by catching the error
in here cache within the parentheses we
can catch any type of exception here and
then in the finally block which is
basically an optional block we are
checking something like if this value
verification is null because if in any
case if this mul greater than zero
function returns an error then that case
this value verification will be now
right by definition it is null and if
it's success then it will this variable
will get the value so in the finally
block we are checking that if that is
null that we are printing value is not
accepted otherwise we are printing value
verified and the
we're using the sting interpretation we
are passing the Velo so let's run this
program you see in first cases it is
showing volute in but when we in the
second case when we are passing the
values zero in the first case it is
printing will you verified by ten but in
the second case it is this catch block
basically captured this exception that
value must be greater than zero you see
this this message is printing in here
but after the exception word and then in
the finally block we also captured the
value I mean the message and here it is
printed Velo is not accepted basically
when you use the catch keyword and
within the princess you use any
parameter like e it basically handles
all kinds of error but if your program
has a specific type of ero you can use
the on keyword so after the try block
you have to use on then the exception
name then if you have another type of
ero then you can use on and that
exception name and sometimes anything is
that is an exception you can use like
this on exception catch e so this is
another pattern but normally I prefer or
in the most cases I use the try catch
block or try catch finally block I
normally do not use the on exception
thing unless it is very important for
the particular program so I hope that
this tutorial will help you to
understand dart programming language and
you can able to dive deep in flatter
framework if you liked this video please
give a thumbs up and if you have any
question please ask in the comment
section I also welcome you to visit my
personal YouTube channel where I
regularly publish programming related
video tutorials so thank you for
watching and have a nice day